on connaît tous quelqu'un on a tous
connu quelqu'un qui avait mauvaise
haleine en fait je pense qu'il va passer
de dentifrice pour tout le monde sur
cette planète
en fait le pire c'est de connaître
quelqu'un qui est dans ta classe et qui
a très mauvaise haleine mais dans la
réalité ce que les autres voient c'est
ça ouais ça super lap
ouais mais toi ce que tu ressens c'est
plutôt simple c'est horrible
toi évidemment comme tu as du respect
pour les gens le cas tu peux prêter 5
euros s'te plaît devenant maire d'auch
[ __ ] tu en seras jamais lui dire
clairement qu'il a très mauvaise haleine
donc tu vas désespérément tenté de
glisser des messages subliminaux pour
qu'ils comprennent qu'ils se brosse
enfin les dents
[Musique]
en fait généralement les gens qui ont
mauvaise haleine ils sentent pas le
compte
pourtant avec les tonnes de messages
lumineux que tu veux rappeler c'est
toujours pas foutu de s'en rendre compte
comme chez ba ba des cafés de l'institut
de danse fluide en ligue 1 qui sait
quelqu'un me personnes
je reprends pas chaque jour un tube de
dentifrice sur trouve mon sac
[Applaudissements]
mais il ya des situations je me dis
quand même à un moment il devrait
réaliser que ce qu'ils ont mauvais ça
craint de fins et de m c'est la nature
sortiront enlevé de la laine pour vous
expliquer clairement le truc quoi
prendre un exemple très simple le
mettent ils en couple tranquille
il alla moi comme ça devant la bouche
presse qui se fait chier et il soupire
non le mec lui au lieu de réagir comme
ça [ __ ] merde je peux les gages j'ai
oublié de me brosser les dents ce matin
j'espère que personne n'a senti mes
repères merde
il va plutôt réagir comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pourtant merde quoi j'ai dcid
quitteront pas sérieux s'cusez moi
j'étais en retard chez courir çà et là
et des fois dans le désespoir tu vas
essayer de tenter quelque chose pour
réduire cette abomination beau mec tu
vois je regarde tu veux j'en ai plein et
l'apathie si on regarde
merci mec c'est cool sauver sauf que un
jour voilà ce qui m'est arrivé
selon m josh eagle t'inquiète pas je
n'ai pas n'y a pas de souci est gratuit
non c'est mon taquet tu peux le garder
je connais bien enfin bref on paye qui
regarde cette vidéo si tu sens mauvais
de la laine ou installés dans ce matin
et soir même peut-être le midi elie
avant le 4 heures et la nuit aussi à
quoi tu es triste
sinon voilà ce qui se passa comme tu
soufflera sur la caméra